duet 14 says you studied computer
science and economics how these fields
impacted your thinking and if you go
back would you still pursue the same
education and why or why not
um i would pursue similar i would say
that microeconomics was incredibly
useful macroeconomics was mostly useless
the part of computer science that was
very theoretical like algorithms and
mathematics was actually the most useful
because that stuff doesn't change over
time the part that was learning to
program in java or fortran was used less
or less useful because it fades over
time
so i would probably do more math more
physics
stick to micro everything
and i would have probably studied some
psychology and some evolution
because i think those are really
important to understanding how humans
work and at the end of the day you're
interacting with humans everywhere you
go
i want to focus on theory and principles
over facts because facts fade or facts
can be looked up
and probably the most important skill is
not really even what you major in what
you study it's just knowing how to learn
and if you have a good grasp of
mathematics and if you'd like to read
there's nothing you can't learn on your
own
alfred north whitehead
said at one time that the rapid advance
of civilization
came only when man invented the method
of invention and of course he was
referring to the huge growth in gb
gdp per capita and
all the other good things that we now
take for granted which happened just
started a few
hundred years ago
and when before that
all was stasis
and
so if
if
civilization can progress only when it
invents the method of invention
you can progress
only when you learn the method of
learning
i was very lucky
i came to law school
having learned the method of learning
and uh and nothing has served me
better in my long life
than
continuous
learning
and if you take warren buffett if you
watched him with a time clock
i would say half
of all the time that he spends is just
sitting on his ass and reading
and a big chunk of the rest of the time
is spent talking one-on-one either on
the telephone or personally with highly
gifted people
whom he trusts and who trust him
in other words it looks
quite academic all this worldly success
[Music]
you